buzzer dome may have issued a life of
luxury but the same can hardly be said
of today's Chinese up-and-comers
austerity measures traffic restrictions
credit tightening slowing economy be
damned Rolls Royce for one is predicting
another record year in China which last
year surpassed the US as the luxury
carmakers biggest market talking to
captains of industry entrepreneurs
basically the columns of the economic
growth in China that is very very
important that they see themselves
reflected in the way how we service them
in any growing economy you're going to
have people who have disposable income
and oftentimes they they're they're well
situated regardless of what happens to
the economy and if they choose to buy a
car they're going to do it I've test
driven a few cars in my day but never a
Rolls Royce again I really hope they are
enjoyed here we go I got the car all to
myself
Beijing driving is not for the faint of
heart especially when you're driving a
seven hundred and seventy thousand US
dollar car this car is very much
attracting software that's very much
younger customers I have been to a
dealer opening yesterday and coming and
we have seen potentially around 15
sports car drivers Ferraris Lamborghinis
and they are all highly attracted for
the first time baris Royce yo baby
beautiful pics up so quickly I need one
of these it's not just the foreign
brands that are trying to capture the
ultra-luxury segments in China local
brands like Chung on check out this
extended wheelbase it keeps on going and
going and yes excuse me and going and
hmm great wall wine the premium sector
has continued to surprise most of the
industry observers it has grown 30
percent already in the first quarter of
this year showing no signs of abating I
think there is such a vibrant growth to
the Chinese economy and as income levels
are rising so people are also wanting to
avail themselves of the aspirational
brand so I have no concerns about the
growth potential well all good things
come to an end my time behind the wheel
of the race is over and I did not put a
single scratch on it mission
accomplished
Steven angle Bloomberg Beijing